Welcome to the channel and my name is
Paul.
Today I'm going to talk about the
Swahili language or Kiswahili as it's
called in Swahili,
and by the way,
Keith is a prefix that means language.
Swahili is one of the most widely spoken
languages in Africa,
and if we only consider languages that
are native to Africa,
then it is the most widely spoken.
It is widely spoken over a wide area of
east Africa.
The number of native speakers of Swahili
is actually rather small,
somewhere between five and 15 million,
but it is widely spoken as a Lingua
Franca that unites the linguistically
diverse population.
Estimates vary,
but the total number of proficient
speakers,
if we include second language and third
language speakers,
could be as high as $150 million or even
more Swahili,
is an official language in Kenya,
Tanzania,
Uganda and Democratic Republic of Congo,
and it's spoken in other countries like
Rwanda and Burundi.
The closely related Korean language
spoken in Comoros.
There's also sometimes considered a
dialect of Swahili.
Chances are that you know a little bit
of Swahili already,
whether you know it or not.
If you've seen the Disney movie lion
king,
then you know the name Simba.
Simba means lion in Swahili,
and maybe you remember Nala,
Nala means gift in Swahili.
Then there's roughly d,
Rafiki means friend in Swahili,
and of course there's Puma.
Puma means stupid in Swahili,
and of course there's Hakuna Matata.
Tata means no worries in Swahili,
Simba,
Nala,
Rafiki,
Aquanaut,
my dad,
Swahili is one of the two languages
that's a traditional branch of the
Nigeria Congo language family,
throw around $250 into languages
depending on what we consider our
language versus a dialect.
The history of Swahili is somewhat
unclear,
but it originally developed as a
language of coastal areas of Kenya and
Tanzania.
Fishermen spread the language to nearby
islands.
Then over the following centuries,
traders from these islands spread the
language to a larger area of the coast.
Today,
this coastal region stretching from
southern Somalia all the way down to
northern Mozambique is where most of
Swahili native speakers are.
Found.
The areas where Swahili is spoken had a
lot of interaction with foreign traders,
particularly those from the Middle East,
throughout the Middle Ages.
One of the main commodities the traders
were seeking was close,
so person in Arab traders established
cloves,
farms in Zanzibar archipelago,
and they also established trading
settlements along the mainland coast
with both foreign traders and local
African Swahili speaking trader,
settling along the new trade route,
Swahili absorbed many foreign loan
words,
especially from Arabic.
In fact,
the name of the language itself while he
lead,
comes from Arabic.
The Arabic word for Kostas side and the
plural form is so,
uh,
so with the prefix key key Swahili means
the language of the coasts.
In large part,
this interaction between foreign Muslim
traders and local Africans is what made
the Swahili language what it is today,
a Bantu language with a large number of
loan words from other languages,
especially Arabic,
but also Persian,
Malaya and other languages to contact
with European colonial powers also
influenced Swahili.
Portugal began establishing colonies in
East Africa and 15,
oh,
five ce,
including in Zanzibar and along the
Kenyan intensity and coasts.
And as you might predict,
this led to the adoption of some
Portuguese vocabulary,
but by about 1730 ce Omani,
Arabs have retaken that region from the
Portuguese and reestablished control
over it.
Around that time in the early 18th
century,
Swahili spread further inland with Arab,
ivory and slave trade caravans.
This brought Swahili to more inland
areas of Kenya and Tanzania to the
eastern part of Congo,
northern Uganda,
and Rwanda and Burundi in the mid 18th
century.
The British and the Germans began
colonizing the area.
Germany took Tanganyika or modern day
Tanzania as a colony in 18,
86.
And the British took control of Kenya
then called the East Africa protectorate
in 1895.
And they both encouraged the use of
Swahili as a national language to unite
the population which spoke dozens of
different languages.
Germany made Swahili,
the official end administrative language
and Tanganyika.
While the British made English.
The official language at the highest
levels in Kenya.
English was the language for National
Administration and for higher education,
but Swahili was made the language for
local administration and for primary
education in order to help spread the
Swahili language.
It needed to be standardized,
so in 1928,
a conference was called for this purpose
and the dialect of Zanzibar was chosen
as the basis for the standard language,
its status as an official language or
national language as well as the
language of education has made Swahili
widely spoken as a second language or
third language in Kenya and Tanzania and
in the eastern part of the Democratic
Republic of Congo.
In Tanzania.
Around 80 percent of the people can
speak it and amongst the younger
generations it is becoming more widely
spoken as a native language,
especially in the urban areas and the
situation is similar.
In Kenya,
in the Democratic Republic of Congo,
it's most widely spoken in the eastern
part of the country,
but in total around 50 percent of the
population are proficient in the
language.
It is also fairly widely spoken in
Rwanda and Burundi and to some extent in
Uganda as well.
But even though Swahili has been made an
official language in Uganda and it is
compulsory to learn in schools.
A lot of people are not interested in
learning it and a lot of schools have
actually been teaching it.
At least that's what I hear.
So what is Swahili like orthography?
Well,
it used to be written in the Arabic
script,
but because of European colonial
influence,
it is now written in the Latin script
and it's written phonetically so that
each letter represents just one sound in
the language.
Phonology,
Swahili has five vowel sounds which are
always fully pronounced and not reduced.
There are no diphthongs.
That means that there are no combination
of vowels pronounced as a single
syllable like I or owl,
or if you see two vowels side by side,
they have to be pronounced as separate
syllables.
This makes the phonology generally quite
easy to learn,
and all Swahili consonants have English
equivalents,
but there are some things to be careful
of to nasal consonants can come before
other consonants with no vowel in,
for example,
means child boy means dog means banana.
Learning how to pronounce these sounds
together,
maybe a challenge at first.
If you've never spoken the language with
that feature before.
Grammar articles,
there are no articles in Swahili,
there is no equivalent to awkward that
in the language nouns.
Swahili has a system of now in classes
now in classes or categories of
different types of nouns that are
represented by specific prefixes,
in most cases,
one singular and plural for each type of
note.
First the walk.
Last nouns in this class represents
people or animate beings,
words with the prefix or singular and
those with the wall prefix or plural.
For example,
baby babies,
insect insects.
Another class is the class.
Nouns in this class represent trees or
plants.
Words with them or move prefix are
singular.
While those with the prefix are plural
tree,
two trees need another.
Glass is the glass.
This class includes a wide variety of
nouns,
including some animals,
loan words and miscellaneous other
words.
This is the biggest of the mountain
glasses because of all the loan words in
Swahili,
and for this class,
the prefix denotes both singular and
plural bird birds,
but this class it gets quite complicated
and sometimes the prefix changes.
It changes to an sounds like an m before
a b or a v wine.
And being new wines,
new and other words in this class,
lose their prefix altogether.
So it's interesting to note that an
English,
the plural form,
is indicated by the s suffix at the end
of the word,
but in Swahili,
it's indicated by a prefix at the
beginning of the word.
Now,
in the classes are known to be one of
the biggest challenges facing learners
of Swahili.
Adjectives now in class prefixes are
also applied to adjectives that modify
those nouns.
So the word for good that base form is
Zuni,
but we add a prefix means a good person
who act was judy means good people.
So the prefix changes not only on the
now but also on the adjective adverbs.
Adverbs can be formed from the base form
of the adjective by adding the prefix.
V Good Zuni.
Well,
they got bad badly back.
Here's an example,
sentence it Soma.
He read badly.
Adverbs can also be formed from nouns by
adding the word clock before the theory
means.
Secret.
Quite theory mean secretly.
Verbs aside from now in the classes.
The other main thing about Swahili that
requires some adjustment from learners
is the verbal system.
In Swahili,
a basic verb consists of a subject
prefix,
a tense marker,
and object in fix.
If the object is a separate word and the
verb stem.
Here are some examples,
a taboo.
This means he gave me the book is the
subject,
pronouns,
meaning he is the tense marker
indicating past tense Ne is the object
marker for me,
and pop is the verb.
Stem meaning give and get taboo.
It means book,
and that's a lone word.
From Arabic.
We can change the tense of the sentence
by changing the tense marker I can eat
that could dabble,
so this means he will give me the book
in the future tense.
So we changed the past tense marker to
talk the future tense marker.
Now let's change the subject of the
sentence or could dabble.
That means you will give me the book.
So we changed the subject prefix from
which means he to uber,
which means you.
One interesting thing is that there are
negative subject prefixes.
That means we can make the sentence
negative by using a different subject.
Pronouns.
Here's an example hat.
Any becky tab that means he will not
give me the book,
so remember,
the positive form was taboo.
That meant he will give me the book,
but we changed the AAP to hop and that
is the negative equivalent of the
subject prefix.
So every subject prefix has a negative
equivalent and you have to remember both
and you have to think about which one to
use when you're speaking.
The basic syntax of Swahili is Svo when
there is no object in fix Tambo.
When they're cooler,
this means elephants eat grass in the
sentence.
Ten Bolt means elephant y equals they.
That's the subject prefix,
not equals present tense marker.
Kula equals eat and use equals grasp.
So you can see that when we use a
specific known as the subject,
we still use the subject prefix attached
to the verb.
Another example mean that that cooler,
this means I love eating meat is the
subject.
Margaret meaning I not is the present
tense marker.
Pen De Equals love and cooler equals
eating.
And of course,
that's s v O is Swahili,
easy to learn.
Well,
the pronunciation is known for being
very straightforward and the grammar is
very logical,
but it's also very different unless
you've studied a Bantu language before,
but now in class system and the verbal
system with all of its affixes require
some extra attention to learn.
And for English speakers,
the lack of immediately recognizable
vocabulary might be a challenge,
but if you happen to speak Arabic,
then you will immediately recognize lots
of Swahili.
Vocabulary.
Here are some examples at daddy comes
from Arabic hot daughter,
which means danger.
Chat comes from Arabic Sephardic,
which means travel,
comes from Arabic Mahal,
which means place.
Taboo comes from the Arabic Kitab,
which means book Buddy ed comes from the
Arabic boded,
which means cold and that's just a small
sample.
There are lots of Arabic words in
Swahili,
although the pronunciation has adapted
to fit into the Swahili phonological
system.
Swahili is a unique product of the
history of the east African coast and
the interaction of the local Bantu
people with foreign traders from the
Middle East and elsewhere.
It is becoming more widely spoken and
continues to grow as a Lingua Franca in
east Africa.
If you're planning on living or
traveling in the region or if you just
want to learn about Africa and some of
its cultures than Swahili would be a
great language to learn.
So the question of the day,
for people who have studied Swahili,
what did you find challenging about it,
and what did you find straightforward or
simple about it and for proficient
speakers of Swahili,
how widely spoken is Swahili in your
area?
Is it mostly spoken as a second or third
language or are there lots of native
speakers as well?
Let us know in the comments down below.
Now,
for anyone who doesn't follow Lang,
focus on twitter or on facebook or on
Instagram,
why not?
My name is Lang.
Focus on all of those different social
media channels so you can have a look
for me there and be sure to follow Lang
Focus.
I'd like to say thank you to all of my
patrion supporters.
Thank you for your continued support.
You are very much appreciated.
Even the people who just pledged $1 a
month,
that's all very helpful.
So thank you for watching and have a
nice day.